welcome to this video playing ESO call
this is one of those guys we have a very
bad score three and half out of 12 I
remember that I got lots of good
positions but mostly got swindled when
time and whatever so what happened let's
see what happens CM I some c5 and 97 as
possible but hmm not sure now let's play
conservatively I don't really know how
it works with c5 and so on there are
some light c5 takes 97 I'm not sure this
is here or some other position but i
think that the way I'm playing it here
it should be it should be a should be
okay yeah I'm trying to be quick IAM
remembering that we had those games
where I'm time was decisive
okay so yeah I even be five is a move
it's no no big issue with this i know i
have a five as a possible idea yeah and
this is not not really dangerous i think
so let's school a five or not you can
take them okay
so a five next I guess my bishop he is
really awful but maybe I can get it back
why lc8 yeah I'm try to not fall too far
behind on the clock you here's my
counter play on before now he's just
going to play a six and to give away
before I guess mmm yeah so I don't do
Queenie sound like I originally wanted
so Bishop age six now night over to see
if I home that seems to be the idea ok I
can go back for Bishop c5 maybe and
sorry for Bishop f5 f5 awesome poza was
what I wanted to say I can also go back
be ready to take the take this night
I wasn't doing much on h6 anymore yeah
time-wise I'm okay position also is ok I
think shouldn't be anything special so
what is he doing attacking c6 and clutch
sure how to cover it so this one
difficult to do anything I might have is
61 those kind of moves but
yeah white is a little bit more
comfortable he can I can regroup a
little bit easier
Nia wants to go e 6 cm yeah and she has
these six actually look cat6 that's bad
mm look f6 was a good move okay
Quincy tool probably yeah play he played
that well I guess
that's good for okay 3i guess but no
check check ya know why do I allow root
k 3 is not even doing it ah that was
girls very unnecessary really check time
warning check
yeah it's not exactly fun to play this
check check
yeah you can haz it's made him
we checks from the back to help all
other mousse loss anyway so check check
hmm Derek g6 unfortunately is a lost
king and pawn in game chat yeah it's
lost unfortunately I couldn't really do
anything laughs resigns yeah he played
that well I guess what can you do always
kept kept some some kind of edge I mean
here not here here I was ok but it
drifted into a bad position so wrong
around here that it should be ok I don't
believe it should be somewhat ok i don't
know maybe we did I screw that up yeah
sometimes it's just being a little bit
more precise at things
my engine wants to go rookie to a eight
at this kind of move i played this this
kind of move is always scary for a human
because you think you want to prevent a
move like that so night like this but
it's really not doing much yea maybe
then this is a good idea i mean I'm
threatening things maybe what has to go
e6 here and then here that's the
computer nine rookie eight quincy three
with a draw it's not a very logical draw
yeah i mean this might be equal if if
black has another time and place place
great but i really didn't have any great
idea i am here here that's clear here
i'm just suffering yeah i mean 93 is
just bad of course but ok ok getting
into the Zen game is a mistake i think
because my king is there is yes IAM so
Chaz Higgs Chang maybe really rugae for
what this this cannot be bad and this is
a total lemon yeah I don't know I
immediately saw okay three which he
didn't do for four I know it's in pretty
much not explicable why I didn't do that
yeah maybe ok 10 so i would be six is
just I just I wanted to wait but ok he
didn't do anything with this with this
gift check and here i wonder why don't I
play this is very strange here I can
just do something like this and being
ready for the king move and the engine
just gives equal completely equal it to
complete equality I don't know it's
still a bit annoying to play chat in the
game it went down shyly check ok choose
two drawers here because of you give to
ya now it's chan chan cannot be saved
yeah tough game tough game but you
always kept some kind of some kind of
pressure on it was was difficult to play
ok thanks for watching